so I have a very interesting video today
on the most common mineral deficiency in
the world
but before I dive in I just wanted to
say thank you for subscribing just today
I counted up the total number of
subscribers on all languages because now
my YouTube channel is translated into
Arabic Russian Taiwanese and many other
languages
the total number of subscriptions is
over 18 million subscribers 18 million
I'm blown away so thank you for
subscribing all right now that that's
out of the way what is the most common
mineral deficiency on the planet well
the answer is iron deficiency and this
is a very interesting topic because it's
very common
um it's a bit confusing I'm going to try
to simplify it and it's extremely easy
to fix let me run down first the
symptoms if you're a deficient in Iron
so number one you can have hair loss or
hair thinning you can get arrhythmias
your heart goes out of rhythm that could
be an iron deficiency you become fatigue
weakened you can get dark circles
underneath your eyes restless leg
syndrome okay I used to have that
difficulty sleeping in fact the
arrhythmias could keep you up as well
you're on the cold side your tolerance
for coal old is very low your nails can
become split very easily your
concentration is terrible you can't
focus and you may experience a
fibromyalgia or achiness in muscles or
joints these set of symptoms can also
mimic other problems like hypothyroidism
a B12 deficiency a vitamin D deficiency
low testosterone and even sleep apnea
now one of the challenges that people
run into when they're trying to evaluate
if they have iron deficiency is they go
to the doctor and sometimes their values
their numbers are normal it shows normal
iron it shows normal hemoglobin and the
doctor might say well
you're fine it could be something else
but uh it's definitely not an iron
deficiency when it could be so the thing
you need to know about iron deficiency
is there's another condition called
non-anemic iron deficiency so that could
be like a pre-anemia type state so you
might not have a severe deficiency of
iron just it could be down somewhat
so they call that subclinical now
there's one thing that can actually help
diagnose an iron deficiency and that's
ferritin okay so let me just explain
that what is ferritin ferritin is a
group of proteins okay a lot of
different proteins that help bind with
iron and store and release iron so
ferritin acts as a buffer if you have
too much iron which is very very
dangerous or you don't have enough iron
so if your ferritin level is low that
can definitely be more of an indicator
that you're iron deficient
however there's other things that might
create this false sense of higher levels
of ferritin for example if you have an
infection okay or you have inflammation
in the body your ferritin levels will be
higher than they should be so that can
really complicate things and make things
very difficult to diagnose anytime
you're looking at a deficiency we should
also talk about an excessive iron so I'm
going to touch on what to do if you have
too much iron in the problems that could
be associated with that as well as we go
through this now I want to run into this
next very interesting area which is why
you might be deficient in the first
place and there's a lot of different
reasons but I just want to say that it's
more common to have
non-anemic iron deficiency than to have
anemia so it's very common that this
iron did not affect the blood yet but in
fact a lot of other parts of your body
and we need iron for other things than
just building hemoglobin iron is needed
to build thyroid hormones iron is needed
to make dopamine iron is also needed for
nerve impulses to work correctly that's
why you would have arrhythmias if you
were deficient and so there's many
different reasons why you need iron but
I will say though I've talked to quite a
few patients
who unfortunately did not find a doctor
that can evaluate deep enough especially
this iron problem and the worst thing a
doctor can do is tell you it's all in
your head that is the wrong diagnosis
when people have these symptoms and
you're told it's all in your head wow
talk about something that can really
elevate your cortisol and piss you off
but I hear it all the time so you really
need to find a doctor that's a good
evaluator that can dig deep and to help
assess different levels of this problem
but I want to give you a lot of
information to think with so you can
sometimes even help your doctor guide
them into a certain area especially the
reason why you're deficient in the first
place so number one is that you're not
consuming enough iron from your diet
that can occur if you're a vegan or even
a vegetarian because the most available
form of iron is the heme iron okay and
that's in animal products like red meat
liver seafood
Etc
the type of iron you get from plants is
non-heme and that is not easily absorbed
in fact you're going to absorb 10 times
less iron from plants like spinach but
iron is also high in oxalates which can
block the absorption of iron so let me
go through the list so number one it
could come from not consuming enough
iron in your diet okay number two having
inflammation in the body inflammation in
any part of your digestive system
whether it's in the stomach is gastritis
or in the intestines okay because if
there's inflammation in those parts your
ability to absorb iron goes down
significantly all right the next one
would be stress The more stress you have
the more trauma that you have
surgeries for example which is a trauma
all these things can inhibit your
ability to absorb iron also a loss of
blood whether you're bleeding or you
donate blood or you have an ulcer or
let's say for example you have I don't
know some type of polyp in your colon
that you're bleeding from and you're
experiencing a loss of blood another
common cause of low iron in your blood
especially if you're aging is low
stomach acids okay if you don't have
enough acid in your stomach you're not
going to absorb iron and other minerals
which is very very common it's called
either
hypochlorhydria or a or hydria and the
way that you would know that you have
low stomach acid is you have indigestion
gas or even gerd heartburn or acid
reflux or even menstruation another
reason why you might be deficient in
iron is you had a gastric bypass surgery
okay that can cause the deficiency
because you're having less digestive
organs to absorb iron also athletes or
people who exercise a lot can be
deficient in Iron because some of the
iron that you have is stored in the
muscle and as you use your muscle you
use up the iron and that could be one
reason as well all right next one is
antacids any medication that suppresses
acids could cause an iron deficiency
because we need that hydrochloric acid
in the stomach to be able to absorb iron
fibroids okay if you have fibroids that
could be another reason why you're
deficient in Iron also having a greater
need for iron like when you're pregnant
or your breastfeeding or even a young
child in the development needs and
requires more iron also people with
eating disorders usually have an iron
deficiency another thing that's very
very common as far as blocking iron is
phytic acid now that is in all the
grains the soils the bread the pasta the
cereal crackers biscuits waffles all of
these grain carbohydrates have phytic
acid especially the whole grains Okay so
if you consume those foods that could be
the reason why you're a deficient in
Iron but phytic acid is also in lagoons
beans as well as like I said grains now
there's another compound called tannins
in tea and coffee that can block iron as
well so if you're drinking tea all day
long and a lot of coffee you could be
low in iron chocolate has certain
polyphenols which are phytonutrients
that can block iron and of course
polyphenols are also in a lot of other
things like turmeric for example so
turmeric can actually lower your iron
now I'm not saying not to consume coffee
or tea or turmeric okay or even
chocolate I'm just bringing up the
awareness that that could contribute to
a lessening amount of iron but if you're
consuming enough iron at the same time
you're going to be fine red wine okay
red wine has polyphenols and even
cannons that can block the absorption of
iron all right another thing
polymorphism what is that that's
something wrong with your genes there's
a mutation you can get a DNA test I got
it done I'm going to do a video on that
because it's very fascinating it's new
information that can help you find your
weaknesses within your genes so you can
then do things about it you know and
there's all sorts of it's called
epigenetic lifestyle things you can do
with the diet or taking more of a
certain nutrient so the reason I'm
bringing that up is that I tested
positive for this one called MTH fra
slightly different one which does affect
iron
um so I'm bringing it up because
um the genetic defect affecting this
Gene called
MTHFR it can cause you to have less iron
as well as a B12 deficiency
and a folate deficiency and as you may
or may not know if you're low on B12 you
can also be anemic as well a different
type of anemia and folate is very very
important in building red blood cells
the point is there are genetic
weaknesses
that uh go beyond just that Gene that
can affect your ability to absorb iron
and if you're trying to fix this problem
with working on all these other things
and you don't know that there could be a
genetic uh weakness then you can go
round and round and round so the
solution if you have a mutation in your
genes is just to take more and see if
that doesn't handle it and sometimes
people don't just take enough or they
don't take it long enough to see the
changes because sometimes it could take
months to fix a severe deficiency all
right another Factor would be taking too
much calcium or magnesium yeah or
drinking a lot of milk calcium as well
as magnesium can inhibit iron all right
so I just want to bring that up also
infections when you have infection your
body will shut down the amount of iron
available because
this iron is kind of a competition
between the pathogens and your microbes
so your microbes no the pathogens can
eat iron and your microbes also can eat
iron so they will kind of hog the iron
so the pathogen doesn't get it and that
can leave you in a situation where you
have low iron so if you even have a
let's say a subclinical infection
whether it's Epstein-Barr virus or
whatever that could be why you're low in
iron and I already mentioned oxalates
can block iron so oxalates are iron
spinach almonds asparagus okay so I gave
you a long list of all the reasons why
you might be deficient in iron and then
of course then you would correlate that
with your blood tests to be able to see
what's going on and as far as correcting
an iron deficiency I know people will
take supplements and they'll take um
Elemental iron they'll take different
types forms of iron and I'm not saying
that won't work okay but I always
recommend uh trying to get your iron
from food first so start consuming more
red meat liver
shellfish okay and also try to identify
why you're deficient in the first place
if it's low stomach acid start taking
apple cider vinegar or retain
hydrochloride to help the pH so you want
to get to the root cause and also if you
add vitamin C at the same time like in a
salad or sauerkraut you can increase the
absorption of iron now one thing you
could take as far as pills is take liver
pills or another product there's
actually spleen pills you can get that
dehydrated spleen extract that seems to
work really good as an iron supplement
now realize if you're very deficient it
could take weeks to um correct this all
right on the flip side let's say you
have a condition called hereditary
hemochromatosis okay this is a situation
where your body is absorbing too much
iron so you have too much iron and this
is the problem okay it could be very
very toxic I can create problems with
your liver in your heart and your brain
So based on a blood test your doctor can
determine if you have this a problem and
now what you do about it well there's a
couple things I would recommend start
consuming distilled water I would get a
machine to make your own and so it's not
in a plastic jug but a glass jug coming
from stainless steel because distilled
water can start to actually suck out
some of the minerals so just realize
it'll it'll pull out other minerals too
but you can then put the minerals back
in that you want but not the iron one
okay turmeric turmeric can act as a
chelator or something that binds that
iron and can help pull it out of the
body start consuming turmeric cocoa bean
that can help because that has a lot of
polyphenols that can help bind iron and
definitely something like black tea
would also help because it's higher in
tannins which can help bind the iron so
basically we want to take the things
that are inhibiting iron if you're
deficient and start taking those because
you have too much now there's another
thing you could take I mentioned phytic
acid right so you can actually take that
as a supplement to help chelate iron or
bind and remove iron from the body and
you can get that in a form called ip6
okay it's called ip6 that's basically
phytic acid and you start taking that to
help bind the iron and if it's really a
problem and you want something stronger
you can take something called EDTA
that's a very powerful chelator so just
realize you have to put back in those
minerals that your body really needs and
they're non-toxic okay minus the iron
all right I gave you a lot of
information about iron I think the next
most important thing for you to learn
more about would be on how to improve
the digestive system simply because
there are so many things that can go
wrong in the digestive tract that can
affect not just iron but other nutrients
and I put that video up right here check
it out